Welcome to the debate.
I am really glad to have you joining us.
Imagine spending, I mean, your entire life mastering these incredible theological tools.
And then?
And then finding out they are completely useless.
Exactly, useless.
You study the text, you debate the scholars, you build this flawless logical system to understand the divine.
and suddenly they just shatter in your hands.
Today we are looking at a moment of, well, profound intellectual crisis documented in the book The Master and the Disciple.
It is such a fascinating moment, or rather a terrifying one for a thinker to be in.
The disciple, the careful interlocutor, is just standing there, completely bewildered.
Yeah, his words have literally left him.
Because he is cornered by his own logic.
He realizes that everything his theological school taught him just leads to a dead end.
He has to choose between 2 unacceptable options.
Either he accidentally creates a physical likeness for an unimaginable God, or he, you know, settles for empty, abstract vocabulary that basically means nothing.
And walking him out of that crisis reveals something huge.
It is a structural mechanism of the cosmos that is controversial but logically inescapable.
The ultimate conclusion they arrive at is our focus here.
Divine justice itself requires a chain of just witnesses between Allah and His creatures in every age.
But getting to that conclusion requires dismantling all of his deepest assumptions first.
Which is where you come in, taking the seeker's perspective for this discussion.
Yeah, and honestly, you can understand why he clings to those early assumptions.
When you encounter this argument, the initial instinct is to rely on traditional defenses.
Take the strongest version of what we can call the school's credal move.
Lay that out for us.
How does the credal move attempt to solve the problem of the distance between the creator and the creation?
Well, it solves it by saying the distance is the point.
Oh, interesting.
Yeah.
The traditional theologian argues that affirming divine transcendence and divine justice as standalone articles of faith is entirely sufficient, like nothing further must logically follow.
We state that the Creator is utterly beyond human comprehension, separated from all the physical limitations of the created world.
Sure.
At the same time, we affirm that He is just.
By holding these two axioms independently, we protect His absolute majesty.
We do not need to construct a literal, physical bridge or some continuous chain of human intermediaries to resolve the distance.
Because imposing A mechanism feels like a limitation.
Precisely.
Imposing A mandatory structural mechanism diminishes the very transcendence we are trying to protect.
If we force him to use a literal chain of human beings to communicate in every age, we are basically putting him in a box.
The gap itself is a testament to his greatness.
It is an incredibly appealing framework.
I mean, it feels safe.
It honors the majesty of the creator.
But the master, the elder companion in this dialogue, recognizes that the cradle move leaves us shivering in the cold.
In what way?
It allows us to recite beautiful words about a fire without ever feeling its warmth.
A purely abstract God who remains utterly separated from creation leaves the creation entirely in the dark regarding what they are actually supposed to do.
Which leads us directly to the disciples' second defense, what we can call the rationalist move.
If the creedal move protects majesty, the rationalist move protects human intellectual dignity.
The enlightenment ideal, essentially.
We can just figure it out ourselves.
Yes, exactly.
Let me steel man this idea.
The argument is that creatures should be left to reason alone.
The creator endowed humanity with an intellect capable of observing the cosmos, reflecting on morality, and deducing the necessity of obedience.
So independent thought is the divine gift.
Right.
It frames independent thought as a gift.
If he were to install a continuous, physical intermediary who dictates meaning in every single generation, human reason would be reduced to mere obedience.
The rationalist move argues that leaving creatures to discern the truth through their own intellect honors the capacity with which we were created.
I see the appeal of both the credal and the rationalist positions.
They are designed to preserve something vital.
But what happens when we subject those two comforting ideas to a stress test?
They break.
They completely break.
The teacher does exactly that.
He shows that the rationalist move assumes the intellect operates in a vacuum.
It ignores the reality that human beings are born completely ignorant.
The intellect is an engine, but it requires fuel.
It must be taught.
Okay, so these tools cannot survive a formal proof.
Exactly.
The traditional tools cannot survive the scrutiny of a formal proof, which the teacher now constructs.
And this is where the dynamic really shifts.
The disciple is stripped of his comforting theories, and he is forced to answer 3 incredibly simple questions.
Three premises that act as a trap.
The teacher pivots, posing the first question.
Can the Creator be perceived by our vision?
The answer is an obvious no.
He is far above the limits of the physical senses.
Any orthodox thinker agrees immediately.
Premise 2.
Can we hear his speech directly?
Again, no.
And the logic here is crucial.
Speech requires a speaker, described by physical attributes.
Vocal cords, sound waves moving through air.
The Creator is beyond physical description.
So the senses cannot reach him, and the voice of his speech is not a voice we can directly hear.
So far, the disciple is nodding along.
But then comes the third premise.
Would he be unjust to his creatures by imposing impossible obligations
commanding what they cannot perceive and punishing them for failing to do what they had no way of doing.
Let's translate that.
You cannot see him.
You cannot hear him.
But he is perfectly just, which means he is not going to punish you for failing a test that is literally impossible to pass.
Exactly.
The answer, of course, is no.
Anyone who imposes an impossible obligation cannot be just, and the Creator is completely removed from injustice.
The premises are standard.
but the conjunction of these three premises is the lever that upends the disciple's entire worldview.
How so?
If you cannot see him and you cannot hear him, but he is not unjust, then a reaching mechanism is absolutely required.
The community is held to his command, therefore they must be reached by him through something else.
The intermediary is not a luxury or a theological convenience.
It is a necessity.
It is a logical inevitability.
The 3 premises force a single consequence.
Intermediaries are what justice itself requires.
Divine justice itself requires a chain of just witnesses between Allah and His creatures in every age.
I don't buy that yet.
Tell me why.
Even if I accept the three premises, and I do, why must the conclusion be a continuous, physical chain of human witnesses?
Why isn't the human intellect enough of an intermediary?
Because the intellect.
Wait, you dismissed the rationalist move a moment ago, but if the intellect is the reaching mechanism, then justice is satisfied.
The Creator gave us a mind to deduce His laws.
Isn't this just replacing one authority with another?
You are taking the authority of independent human reason and replacing it with the absolute authority of a human intermediary.
I understand why you frame it that way, honestly.
But the intellect is an instrument of reception, not a source of independent revelation.
Let's use a courtroom analogy to break down why the intellect alone cannot generate the law.
Okay.
In jurisprudence, a fundamental principle of justice is that a law promulgated without notice is tyranny.
Meaning you cannot punish someone for breaking a rule they didn't know existed.
Exactly.
You cannot punish a citizen for violating a law they had no mechanism to learn.
This principle is grounded directly in the Quran, specifically verse 1715, which establishes that a courtroom where punishment proceeds notice is unjust.
What does the verse say?
It states, we do not punish until we have sent a messenger.
The intellect can process the message once it arrives, but your intellect cannot magically generate the specific, positive obligations of divine law out of thin air.
The sending of a messenger is the formal notice.
But a messenger in the past provides the notice.
We are not operating in a vacuum today.
The text is written down.
We have the book.
We can use our intellect to read the book and apply it.
Why do we need a continuous chain of witnesses in every age?
Because a book is silent without a speaker.
If the law requires interpretation in a new, unprecedented age, a silent text cannot resolve a live dispute.
It just becomes a mirror for whoever is reading it.
So the text alone is essentially static.
Yes.
which is why the necessity extends into every single generation.
There is a profound saying of the commander of the faithful, peace be upon him, preserved in the book, The Peak of Eloquence.
What does he say?
When pressed about who stands between the Creator and the servants in the present world, he affirms that the earth is never void of a standing argument for Allah.
A standing argument, meaning a living person.
Yes.
Whether that witness is seen by the people or hidden from them, they must exist lest the divine proofs and clarifications be nullified.
To say the earth is empty of a witness is to say the proofs have been nullified.
Which violates the third premise we just established.
Exactly.
If the proof is nullified, humanity is left without notice and any subsequent judgment would be unjust.
I understand the logical structure you are building.
I mean, it is airtight on paper.
But I have to press you on the practical reality of this system.
Go ahead.
How is this different from any tradition that says, trust our chain?
Every sect, every theological school, every tradition, has a lineage of scholars or authorities they claim is the correct one.
If the earth is never void of a standing argument, and we must obey this continuous chain to avoid the wrath of the Creator, it sounds like an arbitrary demand for submission to a specific historical hierarchy.
It sounds like a bodily dynasty.
That is the essential challenge, and it requires us to apply a non-bodily correction to our understanding of this system.
We are not talking about a bodily succession of kings or a mundane political dynasty.
It certainly looks like one from the outside.
Sure.
But the chain does not work like a royal bloodline, where the crown simply passes from the elder son to the younger son as a matter of genetics.
We have to think of the chain as an electrical current.
An electrical current.
Walk me through that.
Think of it like a high voltage electrical grid.
The source of the power is massive, far too massive to plug directly into your house.
If you try to connect the infinite directly to the finite, you burn the house down.
Makes sense?
Every single link in this chain is divine, but they serve different functions to safely step that current down.
The current runs from the upper to the lower.
The witnesses are rank ordered in function, but they are absolutely equal in reward.
Wait, seriously?
You are splitting function and reward?
That sounds like a convenient loophole to justify a secondary class of authorities who come after the original messenger.
How does that actually work without diminishing the later figures?
It is not a demotion.
It is a description of how divine communication actually flows.
In the divine economy,
The superior messenger is like the main transformer.
He is distinguished by receiving direct revelation, the outer word, the massive jolt of power.
Okay.
The subordinate link in the chain receives inspiration by means of that superior messenger.
He routes the power safely into the specific realities of his generation.
Let's look at the historical timeline established in the texts.
Inspiration came to Lot by means of the patriarch.
The source of guidance is exactly the same, but the channel has a specific shape.
So the patriarch receives the direct revelation and Lot receives it through him.
Yes.
The blessing and excellence are assigned to the head, but the subordinates is filled by way of the superior.
The Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family, stands as the ultimate superior messenger of his cycle, bringing the final revealed book.
But the chain of witnesses continues after him to carry the current forward.
So they don't bring a new book.
No, they do not bring a new book.
They maintain the current of the existing one.
That sounds like wordplay, honestly.
How so?
You are creating a hierarchical distinction to justify a secondary class of authorities
come after the original messenger.
By separating the superior, who brings the book, from the subordinate, who interprets it, you are granting these secondary figures the power to introduce hidden meanings that are not obvious in the text.
The hidden meanings argument.
Yes, this is the exact critique leveled by traditional schools, that this mechanism of continuous witnesses is just a license to invent esoteric readings and claim they possess absolute divine authority.
That critique is incredibly common, but it relies on a fundamental misunderstanding of what is actually happening.
It assumes the inner meaning is an invention, a post-hoc edition smuggled into the text by an ambitious successor who wants to control the community.
But the Elder Companion counters this by explaining the nature of the divine deposit.
The deposit being the message itself.
Correct.
There is only one single divine deposit.
but it possesses 2 sides, the outer word and the inner sense.
Both of these sides are released at one single act of inspiration.
Let's use an analogy to ground this.
Think of the outer word as a piece of brilliant sheet music.
And the inner sense.
The inner sense is the master musician who knows exactly how it is supposed to be played.
Okay, so the sheet music is the literal text of the book.
Yes, the superior messenger delivers the sheet music.
But the trustee is designated to carry the inner sense, the actual music.
He does not invent new notes.
He is the custodian of the esoteric interpretation that was baked into the revelation from the very beginning.
So the inner meeting is not deduced later by some clever scholar.
You are saying it is given simultaneously at the exact moment of revelation.
Precisely.
The trustee does not read novelty into the text.
Modern scholars of Islamic philosophy, like Henry Corbin and Farhad Daftary, have pointed out that this isn't just some abstract marginal theory this is the classical Ismaili reading.
It is a...
brilliant central architectural system of cosmic preservation.
The outer and the inner work in absolute lockstep.
They are each indispensable to the other.
Because without the musician, the sheet music is just ink on a page.
And without the sheet music, the musician has no structure to play from.
If you only have the outer word, you have a corpse, a body without a spirit.
You get rigid, lifeless legalism.
And the flip side.
If you only have the inner sims without the outer structure, you have a wraith, a spirit without a body, you get pure chaos where anyone can claim the text means anything.
The continuous chain of witnesses ensures that both halves of the single deposit remain alive and united in the world.
I came into this trying to protect human agency and the absolute transcendence of the Creator.
But when you frame it this way as a strict requirement of divine justice, it actually traps my argument.
It is inescapable.
I hate to admit it, but if the creator's justice requires that we understand the command, and the command has an inner dimension necessary for true comprehension, then a custodian of that inner dimension must exist, because if that living custodian ceases to exist, the text degrades into a dead artifact.
It just becomes subject to whatever the loudest voice or the prevailing political consensus decides it means.
The mechanism of justice breaks down entirely.
The teacher lays down a final,
devastating principle for the questioner to absorb.
He says he does not like his commands to be cut off from his servants after his blessing to them.
Meaning, if the chain of witnesses stops, the blessing is actively withdrawn.
Yes, if the chain stops, the means of worship are withdrawn.
Think about the cruelty of that scenario.
The creator would have built up the heavy duty of his creatures, commanded them to obey under threat of punishment, and then removed the only possible way they could actually discharge that duty.
Stopping the chain would legitimize ignorance.
Because it would mean that a later generation is commanded to obey the exact same laws, but they are denied the living instrument of obedience that the earlier generations enjoyed.
They are handed the sheet music but denied the musician.
Exactly.
It would be a profound violation of the courtroom principle we established earlier.
The very justice that produced the chain in the first place absolutely forbids the chain from being cut.
It cannot be severed.
I have to concede the inescapable weight of this logical sequence.
If one accepts that the Creator cannot be sensed, and that he is not unjust, then he must provide a continuous, accessible means to comprehend his command.
To deny this is to suggest he demands the impossible.
Therefore, this is the very foundation of justice.
Divine justice itself requires a chain of just witnesses between Allah and his creatures in every age.
The logic closes every escape route, leaving the careful interlocutor and us with a profound realization about the nature of divine guidance.
It is not an artifact of the past.
It is not a silent book gathering dust on a shelf.
The call is a living current.
It is ongoing.
Yes.
As we consider the implications of this structural cosmic necessity, I want to leave you with a reflection drawn directly from the material we have explored.
Which command in your own life has been treated as cut off, quietly bracketed, as a historical artifact that no longer addresses you directly?
And what would it cost this week to act as though the living chain still reaches you?